こんにちははじめ社長とイースうださんだなぁ6です休業カードを真似られるか遊んで
ますよねはいもうすぐ新発売のカードがあるんですけどもうそれを国会いち早く
我々遊んでみましょうあろうやっていこうっていう気はちょっとわかんないって方も
いいと思う
ちょっと我々にアースか楽しく
[音楽]
ブービー見てもらおう
あっ人ってまああてバーですよね
耳打ったけどあーもそれでもすぐ分かるそして彼は者目線でいればいいとどうぞ
ああああ確かに取ってもらえればありふれたもんでできますからいっけええ
10 h
ん
yeah
専攻は俺から行かせてもらおう俺のトーン
俺はインゼクター弾するを召喚
なねっ
ヒンジ来たーーだといいんで来たーー
おかしいいる先輩そんな古典刹那に頬張っている
ゼクターダンセルだと
さらに俺はカード2枚セットしてターンエンド
大丈夫2枚セットしてあるからで地雷だよ大事だいる
大船に乗ったつもりでいて俺のターンドロー
俺は手札からツインツイスターを発動
俺は手札を1枚してフィールドの魔法トラップカード2枚を破壊する
ごめんなんですか
後ろなくなっちゃったん
俺はは開発 j 正規ですが移動召喚
このガードが創刊に成功した時デッキから悪魔族を1体連れてくる
er 車ニッチ
一がー
そして俺はでして帰ってグラバッジでエクシーズ召喚
fc ジョーカーん xc 無償かんっ
胃がんの旅人暫定
pane
ダンテ購入費用車美白あるんですけどそして男女の効果初の進んじゃったよ
エクシーズ素材を1つ取り除きデッキの上から3枚を強くそして山前の攻撃力はほぼず
に送ったカードの枚数かけ500ポイントアップする
[音楽]
団体の抗議力が1508
多分強いいくぜ刷毛目
機関とそれ一弾てでダンセルに工芸を
何か良いのか少ないか
ものかなもないダンセルが受ける
イェイイーグルがウケる w
ファー
ha
立ってる
そして断定はパトリヴェール終了時に週表示になる
多分ん
ス美術
高価なこんな感じかな
死後その社員ぞ
俺のターン道俺はもう一体の
インゼクター男性の召喚まだターンせんだと
また男性だぞ
エヴァでは
今から忙しくなるから
インジェクターデッキの特徴モンスターにモンスターを装備する動きでフィールドに
大量のインジェクターモンスターが並んでしまった
そして俺のフィールドには昆虫族が3体
俺はダンセルと天地ピードで鈴福翔館
リングそうかぁ
[音楽]
現れるインジェクターピコファルなぁ
マジっすかん
うん
ちょっと変わった生1000円
ai すよ切れるリンク召喚されたピコファ玲奈はさらに
インジェクターの動きを加速させたのであった
インゼクターを装備しているおかげで俺の線スピードの攻撃力は2600彦バレーなの
攻撃力はファン1100に上昇
やばいん
ものでは俺のモンスターたちが行くぜバトルフェイズ
センチピードです絡まるように攻撃すからマリオ
続いてパワーアップしたピコマレーナで断片を攻撃
ゲイ
引いてい
nao
強化した俺のインジェクターにはか手前しちゃうのだ
どぉすればいいんだ
俺のターン
ドロシー
ハッハー
俺は三振カネボウ技発動相手の魔法トラップカードを全て破壊する
俺のハーピーの羽労基で装備カードを失った今
絶好の攻めるチャンスだ
そして
新たな力リンク相関リンク創刊日が嘘です
テレビ e
勘弁してください
いやリンク某さあだぜぜ弾けるんですよ
ヘェーケルビーニケルビーニじゃないですよ
祈願の黒天使ケルビーニはフィガーモンスターたちをさらに強化し俺はさらなる
モンスターを召喚した
滋賀の寄進てねーかー
覚悟はいいか
バトルぜいてレイカーでセンチメートルに工芸
そう
さらにベアとリーチで紀子バレエ何工芸
ぐうっ
うわぁ
そして
ケルビに
ダイレクトだーっ
[音楽]
1卓ダイレクトアタック誰かだーダイレクトアタックえーっ
me
はいというわけで今回はですね図1月25日発売の新卵白
リンク brains パックに登場するモンスター時間が来るべしケルビーニと
インゼクターコマれいなの音実はレポスタートして出てきてもらいましたがございまし
たアーちゃんすまた次会ったら読んでさーっ入って遊戯を
ルールが変わりましたで今回のパックで今まで
ブービーてください
そしてなんとプレゼントキャンペーンは大荒れみたいでございますみなさんぜひ動画の
概要欄からチェックしてみてください
火遊び mercer
me
ええええええ
[音楽]